today we're going to talk about the 12
simple and very powerful
home remedies that will not only help
you prevent hair loss but also help you
regrow the hair back you know losing
your hair is a devastating experience
and you want to try natural things first
before you try medication simply because
there are side effects so i'm going to
show you 12 very effective
very cool things that you can do that
are pretty cheap they don't cost you
much money so get a piece of paper out
and write these things down now the
first two things i want to talk about
very important very significant but very
few people
are aware of this so if you think about
what the hair is exposed to on a regular
basis well you take a shower and you're
exposing your hair to the water
did you know that the fluoride in your
water creates significant hair loss as
well as acne in your skin yes this is
true the fluoride the flora that is
supposed to be good for our teeth
actually destroys our hair so the first
piece of advice i'm going to give you is
just stop taking a shower
i'm just kidding what you really want to
do is just get a simple shower head that
filters out fluoride okay i found a good
one i'll put the link down below now i'm
not an affiliate or i don't get any
kickbacks from this company but it's a
pretty good shower head that will filter
out fluoride
now that right there could be the reason
why you're losing hair in fact fluoride
also blocks your thyroid
and a hypothyroid condition
can very easily stop your hair growth
all right the next thing you need to
know about is your shampoo
sulfates
sulfates destroy protein and your hair
is made up of 91
protein
so if you're exposing your hair to
sulfate shampoos on a daily basis you're
literally creating all sorts of problems
and inhibiting hair loss so you really
want to make sure you get a sulfate free
shampoo all right those are the two
things that you just need to avoid now
to understand hair loss let's first look
at the mechanism
how most top hair loss medications work
they basically block an enzyme
to inhibit
dht which is a powerful form of
testosterone that tends to burn out the
hair follicles so
testosterone turns into dht a very
powerful form of testosterone
through this little enzyme and so these
drugs inhibit that enzyme the enzyme is
called 5-alpha reductase and people that
have too much dht get this condition
called androgenetic alopecia which is
pattern hair loss both in males and
females all right so now the question is
are there natural things that can
inhibit this enzyme because of course
the drugs have
side effects and the answer is yes so
there's a couple things you can do
onion juice which i put a video on this
one topic is a potent natural inhibitor
of that enzyme so you dilute it in water
okay like a 50 50 ratio rub it into your
scalp and let it set for 15 minutes and
then you would wash out your hair i put
a link down below the video that i did
on this topic all right green tea
same thing you would make some green tea
dilute it by 50
rub it into your scalp for about 15
minutes then wash it out with shampoo
now the next
potent inhibitor of this enzyme is
rosemary oil there's one study that i
found that showed that this oil
is comparable
to rogaine as far as the effectiveness
for preventing hair loss and so you
would take rosemary oil rub it into the
scalp and leave it on for about 10 to 15
minutes
and you would actually leave it in
overnight and then in the morning take a
shower shampoo your hair so rosemary oil
is a potent inhibitor of five alpha
reductase now another inhibitor of this
enzyme is just zinc okay maybe you're
deficient in zinc like a lot of people
are so the best food for zinc is oysters
start consuming some oysters a few times
a week but zinc is also in red meat so
you might need some more red meat it's
also in seafood it's also in eggs but
red meat and oysters have the most zinc
okay now we have five the old-fashioned
home remedy apple cider vinegar
you don't want to put
concentrated apple cider vinegar on your
scalp okay i'm just letting you know
right now it's going to burn your scalp
you want to dilute it like 1 3 cup of
apple cider vinegar to one liter of
water and you can rub it into the scalp
and it actually will help clean up some
of the pores that may be filled with
sebum which is an oil that could be
preventing the follicles from growing
properly and also apple cider vinegar
gives a really nice shine to your hair
in addition to that apple cider vinegar
is acidic and so is your scalp so apple
cider vinegar can help re-establish the
ph of your skull which can actually
support the friendly microbes or the
microbiome in your scalp you don't want
to create an environment where the
outside of your skin is so sterile
because you have
millions of microorganisms living on the
outside of your skin
helping you and when you sterilize or
clean your skin too much
you can end up with all sorts of
problems including hair loss so this is
why you want to minimize the amount of
chemicals that you expose your skin to
let's go to number six
what if you go on the ketogenic diet and
you start losing hair what does that
usually indicate that usually means that
you're not consuming enough protein
that's the number one cause so increase
your protein okay there's some other
things you want to look at as well
number one trace minerals especially
if you are doing intermittent fasting or
fasting with your ketogenic plan because
we are very very deficient in trace
minerals in our food trace minerals are
minerals needed in very small amounts
but they're very very essential so
either consuming food high in trace
minerals like sea kelp or shellfish or
fish from the ocean and
sea salt is a good one or just get a
plant-based trace mineral product will
add more trace minerals to give the hair
what it needs to build all right the
other key vitamins that are needed in
larger amounts when you're on the
ketogenic plan are the b vitamins and so
there are a lot of links between a b
vitamin deficiency and hair loss so you
want to make sure
you're taking enough vitamins and so
nutritional yeast is a really good
remedy for that just make sure that when
you're doing nutritional yeast
that you want to get it unfortified with
synthetic vitamins all right number
seven cruciferous vegetables
if you have too much estrogen that can
affect your hair this is why women when
they go through their menstrual cycle
tend to lose hair this is an excess
amount of estrogen and so one of the
natural ways to help regulate estrogen
is to start consuming cruciferous
vegetables another great way to regulate
estrogen would be to take sea kelp
because when you take sea kelp you get
more iodine and iodine also regulates
estrogen now one more side note on that
let's say you're menopausal and you
start losing your hair
that usually is higher levels of
cortisol related to stress
and if that's your situation i put a
link down below on cortisol because
that's a very very important topic let's
talk about number eight
selenium next home remedy would be
something to support a
hypothyroid condition
if you have a slow thyroid a lot of
times you'll lose hair and one of the
key trace minerals for the thyroid to
support it and help convert t4 to t3 is
selenium and the best food for selenium
is
brazil nuts and
seafood
and seaweed or seek kelp now if you do
see kelp you also get the iodine that's
also
good for your thyroid and one note about
that
you can have a hypothyroid condition
from other reasons that are not related
to selenium for example you can have
high estrogen
too much estrogen inhibits the thyroid
function
you could have a fatty liver or liver
damage that can stop your t4 from
converting to t3 you could have
gut damage from antibiotics from eating
the wrong foods
especially gluten i would say out of all
the foods that is damaging to the
thyroid it would be grains specifically
the gluten in the grains okay so if you
have hashimoto's which is usually 90 of
all hypothyroid cases you definitely
need to avoid gluten like the plague
because that will keep the thyroid
inflamed and you're going to have a
difficult time
fixing that problem then we have nine
increase your vitamin d you want to get
more sleep and you want to start
exercising to reduce stress
stress
is a huge
uh problem with your hair in fact a lot
of people if you ask them when did you
lose your hair after an emotional
stressful event because you're spiking
cortisol and cortisol is very damaging
to proteins now a couple things you can
do if this is your situation start
taking more vitamin d
in fact you just need to be on the sun
more if you can do that now if it's
winter it's going to be a hard time but
more vitamin d can greatly greatly help
your hair
and lower your stress vitamin d3 can act
like a natural cortisol hormone but
without the side effects it does very
similar things it's an anti-inflammatory
so to reduce stress
you want to increase your vitamin d and
or expose yourself to sun you want to
get more sleep i have a ton of videos on
that if you're new to my channel you
want to start doing daily walks and you
want to start exercising to reduce
stress all right number ten in a lot of
hair formulas they add silica okay
silica gives the hair its strength and
most spring water has silica like
pellegrino and even most other types of
bottled water where it comes from a
spring is going to have silica you can
even buy silica rich water which is
really good for the hair in fact you're
probably going to notice that your skin
your hair and your nails will all just
start growing and become very strong if
you start consuming silicone alright 11.
the ketogenic diet as well as doing
intermittent fasting if you are female
and you have polycystic ovarian syndrome
you have to realize that one of the big
side effects is hair loss because you
have this spike of androgens and that's
coming from
insulin
so just by
understanding that simple relationship
and lowering the amount of insulin you
can help lower androgens and help
prevent hair loss so how does that
happen well start going on a low carb
diet that's called the ketogenic diet as
well as doing intermittent fasting and
lastly 12. if you look at a lot of
remedies for hair loss supplements they
always add biotin now what's this biotin
biotin helps proteins in your body
especially hair
biotin will help regrow your hair and
prevent the loss of hair but biotin is a
very key b vitamin for the manufacturing
of these proteins that give the hair its
structure and
biotin
is made by bacteria okay so your own gut
makes biotin
and so many people after they lose the
gut
microbiome
start losing their hair because they
don't have the microbes to make biotin
anymore
so take a while guess what food is
loaded with biotin and
can increase your own
friendly bacteria to make your own
biotin
sauerkraut sauerkraut has a hundred
times more probiotics than most
probiotics and the good bacteria in
sauerkraut survives the acid in your
stomach plus it gives you
massive amounts of vitamin c which is
also needed to help grow proteins
specifically collagen and keratin so
sauerkraut on a regular basis can
greatly help you reestablish your
microbiome in your gut help give you
vitamin c
and
give you more biotin now if you have a
receding hairline i did a very specific
important video on that topic and i put
it right here
check it out
you